in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Todd
and Alison are with us hey guys how are
you
welcome welcome good to have you where
do you guys live Culpepper Virginia fun
and what is that near nothing really
okay what's it what's the biggest city
that it's closest to Oh DC yeah over on
that side of Virginia okay cool I just
never heard of colpepper fun welcome
welcome good to have you guys and you're
here to do a debt-free screen you paid
off
we paid off fifty four thousand three
hundred and sixty six dollars and eight
cents I love it how long did that take
you about fourteen months good job way
to go and income range during that time
about 110 excellent very good what do
you guys do for a living I'm a nanny
mm-hmm I work in security operations
very cool all right so what kind of debt
was the $54,000 everything way normal
yeah had everything all normal American
family so what was it card that student
loans every everything at 0% financing
we did write a card
yep credit cards even our iPhones yeah
what was the largest debt student loans
for sure what was the smallest debt um
washer and dryer so you bought us
borrowed on everything yeah pretty much
anything that you want to just wouldn't
got it yeah now let you do it you just
sign your name yeah oh yeah very cool so
what happened 14 months ago it was
probably a year before I heard you come
on the Bobby bones show yeah also in
Nashville and I came to him and I was
like this guy was on the radio and he
said you don't need a car payment and
here we are you know with a car payment
and he said you can be a millionaire and
you got a you just need to listen to
what he said and so he listened and I
don't know if millionaire clicked with
him or what but a few months later he
started reading the book uh-huh as he's
reading it he's like look we have to do
this look everything was common sense so
you can't argue it you know so
December 2014
he finished the book and we were like
new year we're starting we're gonna get
debt-free in 2015 so January 1st we
started and
there you go just like that yeah oh
Bobby's a friend and the whole gang down
there is so they'll be thrilled to hear
they had part in your story yeah
absolutely very fun you guys are
incredible very fun
so did you sell anything on the couch
yeah little stuff here and there nothing
big though
no we just lived on beans and rice yeah
pretty much we both picked up extra work
when we could you know freelance or
babysitting or I mean you guys had been
making 110 and spending 120 yeah and you
went from that to living on 50 all right
yeah we got pretty lucky last year he
got a great bonus and we were and that
was that like the start when we first
started it so it really you know we were
like wow we can pay off three of our
debts with just you know that one check
right so that's the first time in your
lives you'd ever thought that way right
exactly how long have y'all been married
be three years June first yeah all right
so half of your married life's been
doing this right and half of it was
doing it the other way yeah plus all
your adult life before that you're just
buying stuff and so it's just like boom
this hits you guys yeah that's
interesting that it got your attention
that hard and that fast and sucked you
into the Total Money Makeover book which
then caused the whole thing very
interesting very interesting so I mean
this is an incredible feat I know
numbers and hun budgeting I've done this
a long long time and I can see that you
you really dramatically change I mean
just alone eating out yeah that'll kill
you it's ridiculous
yeah that's a big thing and he we both
started taking lunches and guys that
work made fun of me because I never ate
with them yeah the family make fun of
you oh really support oh no good you
know I think if they were like looking
at us like why you know because nobody
else is doing it around us and not for
us so we were probably pretty weird to
everyone and I'm sure they're tired of
hearing Dave Ramsey David
like sorry we can't do that you know
well you were pioneers I mean you went
west when nobody believed you could yeah
that's pretty cool
yeah and anytime we got extra money
whether it be birthdays Christmas it all
went toward that like we didn't give
each other birthday presents we done
that it kinda becomes like a game though
you know it's not forever right and then
we're gonna be able to live like no one
else the other part of it right and so
it's just like kill kill kill kill kill
and you get after it and that it does if
you change your mindset that way it's
just like a board game and I'm just
gonna I'm gonna lean into this and knock
it out it'll be over in 14 months
that's what I had to keep telling myself
you know it's only for like you know at
the time I don't know if we had it
planned out for 14 months but we
actually finished sooner than we thought
no just you know what was the lowest
moment emotionally when you almost quit
when we probably when we started paying
off the bigger deaths they get harder
when you don't see the change so money
but it's the snowball wall right yeah at
the back end of the thing yeah what was
the last debt of student loan yeah and
how much of the 54 was it 17 8 oh yeah
yeah that's you cuz you had a bunch of
little ones then yeah we did you were
getting regular feedback the car was
close behind that 16 okay if not at 17
also those two big ones there yeah that
was half of it only half of it yeah
okay all right very cool that's a great
story you guys are heroes proud idea
Jesus very very good I mean you took
control of your life you now own your
destiny it's got to give you confidence
for all areas of your life you can make
things happen
we're so excited for the future to start
you know eventually down the road having
kids and setting that up you know
changing the family tree and no I think
that's what keeps us going to Italy
what's ahead well on your way to being
millionaires and then you make one
hundred and ten thousand you're on the
payments you don't have any payments
this was the first month we didn't have
any payments and here's you know our
zero based budget
all this money's left over and we just
like there's so money well oh that's
awesome
that is awesome so what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is budget for sure I guess um every
dollar using every dollar we started out
with Excel she and then in March she
came out with every dollar and we were
so excited because I can you know get on
my phone and put in what I just spent
and he can do it from his phone and it's
so easy yep we can look back and see
what we spent make sure we're still on
track and all that becomes exaggerated
budget communication tool when you have
tracking together on their phone
generally that's very cool I'm glad
every dollar folks will be glad to hear
that that's gonna make their day we're
proud of you guys congratulations thank
you alright Todd and Allison from
Culpepper Virginia $54,000 paid off yeah
baby in 14 months making a hundred and
ten a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
I love it I love it oh man that is so
powerful you know if you've had a
question that you've always one of these
one of these debt-free screamers to be
asked once you email it to me at Dave on
air that Dave Ramsey calm and I'll ask
one of them the question if it's a
reasonable question that is you know
it's pretty cool stuff so it because I
do ask the same questions over and over
but what I'm trying to let you know is
not only are real people doing this
every day but they're doing the same
things it's sarcasm when I say what is
the secret to getting out of debt
because it's not a secret
you hear it over and over and over again
commitment passion being on the written
budget together using every dollar calm
working together communication or
couples that are married you know and
being willing to sacrifice to win being
willing to live like no one else so that
later I can live and give like no one
else there's no secret to this the only
question is when are you going to do it
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you